si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain il existe pourtant une
solution naturelle qui a fait ses
preuves depuis des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensait plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec feed aux nuits alors si
vous le permettez on va utiliser la
technique que vous aviez dans cela rime
pulse
donc je vous invitais et nos auditeurs
aussi attendre le point comme ça et a
concentré toute l'attention sur
simplement le pouce devant et puis c'est
vraiment très facile il suffit de serrer
encore davantage le point et vous verrez
que toutes les tensions ont tendance à
se diriger vers le point en tout cas
toutes les sensations de tensions vont
vers ce point et en même temps que les
sensations de tensions vont vers ce
point et bien on observe que le bras
semble un petit peu comme en lévitation
un peu comme un avion séparer des restes
du corps c'est quelque chose d'assez
amusant et ça devient de plus en plus
fassiez de se concentrer de se
concentrer sur ceux poux sur l'ongle du
pouce de prendre une profonde
inspiration de fermer les yeux et de
garder quelques instants encore cette
inspiration puis d expirer en relâchant
tourner ouvre la main on ouvre la paume
de la main et on peut la laisser
descendre comme ça par petit à coup
tranquillement un petit peu comme si
elle était dotée d'une vie propre
un peu comme un très beau planeur
un peu comme cela rime pulse porté par
le vent est nourri par l'énergie solaire
la main peut descendre à son rythme et
vous allez peut-être avoir la surprise
de vous sentir de plus en plus détendu
parce que la respiration va se ralentir
elle va devenir plus lent plus calmes
plus douce et vous aller progressivement
entrer dans une sorte d'intériorisation
comme le disait bertrand piccard on va
s'abstraire progressivement de
l'extérieur pour rentrer de plus en plus
en soit en contactant soient et quand la
main aura touché le lit le fauteuil vos
genoux peu importe vous pourrez laisser
votre respiration s'approfondir
d'avantagé commencé progressivement
entrer en transe
rien ne presse c'est normal certains
moments que certains mots vous échappe
ce sera les moments où seraient
davantage en transe
et puis il suffit de se laisser porter
par la voir mais aussi simplement que si
je vous racontais une histoire de toute
façon quand on raconte une belle
histoire et qu on est transporté par la
voir dans d'autres pays pour vivre
d'autres vies et bien certainement se
mettront aussi en entrant dans une
transe de plus en plus profondes et 12
et c'est agréable de laisser maintenant
le bras se reposait le corps se détendre
et de commencer une plongée progressive
à l'hypnose au départ nous serons comme
votre père et votre grand père des
pionniers nous allons descendre de plus
en plus profondément comme bathyscaphe
comme un sous marin vert
l'intérieur de soi et cela ne demande
aucun effort juste à se laisser porter
et même si à certains moments on fait
des efforts justement la fatigue invite
à plonger davantage en soit à se laisser
porter il y à cette voix qui vous
accompagnent qui devient toujours plus
présente en vous toujours plus agissante
et les bruits l'extérieur maintenant
change c'est un petit peu comme s'ils
vous traversait les sensations
deviennent plus précise
la respiration plus lente et en fonction
de la manière de focaliser l'attention
peut-être sur le contact de l'air contre
le visage contre les mains par exemple
importe les sensations devienne plus
forte parce que vous rentrez dans votre
monde intérieur à mieux parce que vous
rentrez dans votre monde intérieur à
mesure que vous arriver progressivement
et sans effort à vous abstraire de
l'extérieur et comme nous et émotionnels
sont très liés à la respiration
on a vu tout à l'heure ne peut se
stresser avec la respiration pour être
plus éveillés et on peut la ralentir
pour rentrer davantage en soi pour se
détendre alors j'aimerais que vous
donniez un élan nouveau à cette détente
à cette transe
simplement en prenant deux inspirations
profondes comme un champion d'apnée qui
s'apprêterait à plonger dans l'océan
pour y voir des merveilles et qui
prendrait deux inspirations profondes
pour aller dans un monde différent si
proche si l'on en même temps vous allez
plonger de plus en plus à l'intérieur de
vous même et cela va être de plus en
plus agréable la respiration toujours
plus lente toujours plus calmes et
j'aime beaucoup cette image des racines
de calme
la respiration plan sans passer par les
narines se diffuser ensuite dans les
poumons et c'est vrai que ce sont des
racines de calme le corps leur sens et
ceux des temps à son rythme pour entrer
toujours plus en transe toujours plus
canon et nous plongeons toujours un peu
plus loin quatre
un peu plus loin mais un peu plus proche
de vous même et les sensations progresse
de nouvelles sensations
c'est la respiration qui devient un peu
plus lourde
un peu plus qu'à non plus un peu plus
profonde
alors on peut observer le corps quelques
instants les bras
détendu un peu plus lourd les jambes
plus lourdes c'est également tout le
corps
c'est un peu comme si on laissait le
corps lourd plonger davantage en transe
de plus en plus loin la découverte de
vos ressources inconsciente et dans
cette dissociation des merveilleux de
sentir l'esprit lui plus léger près
arrivé en même temps prêt à s'observer
quand il le faut et à travailler sur soi
vip l'esprit s'allège d'où ce nom à son
rythme en plus le corps pèse lourdement
elia une étude qui a été faite sur
l'hypnose qui montre que l'on peut
augmenter la durée du sommeil lent et
profond
il prenait l'image d'un poisson il
faisait rêver qu'on était un poisson
calais de plus en plus profondément dans
l'océan vers les abysses là je vous
propose de faire ce même voyage
cette fois ci aborde un bathyscaphe
votre sous-marin celui qui a été inventé
à le père et le grand père de bertrand
piccard imaginez simplement que vous
êtes dans ce bathyscaphe ce sous marin
qu'à chaque respiration pour lâcher du
lest
je vous allez un pont plus profondément
au départ c'est agréable de pouvoir
sentir cette douceur dans le corps peut
être d'observer en eau les vagues les
lumières et de sentir qu'on peut à
chaque respiration s'enfoncer plus
profondément dans l'océan voir de
nouvelles espèces de poissons de
nouvelles créatures et plus lumière
diminue plus un sentiment de paix de
tranquillité plus la transe devient
profonde tout cela s'installe on vous
chaque expiration de sous-marins
s'enfonce davantage conscients que au
fond des océans dans les abysses il
trouvera les plus mystérieuses et les
plus belles créatures faire de l'hypnose
c'est un peu ça c'est aller à la
découverte d'une richesse intérieure
l'on ignore compte le philosophe disait
qu'on ne peut pas être observateur
observer c'est tellement vrai avec
l'hypnose on peut vivre ses ressources
inconscient découvrir toutes ces choses
que l'on ignorait sur soi la
multiplicité de ses capacités de ses
potentiels de ces ressources et dans ce
voyage toujours plus profondément dans
l'océan ont sa profonde il approfondit
la transe et la respiration devient plus
calme et les bras plus lourd et les
jambes plus lourdes
comme il est doux de découvrir cette
capacité que l'on a en nous
in et à se sentir bien se sentir sera et
cela donne envie évidemment de la
développer cela donne une confiance en
notre capacité à être bien à bien dormir
aussi profondément dans un sommeil de
plus en plus profonds écarts est lourd
et tranquille
et lorsque vous atteindrez le plancher
des océans la fosse des mariannes de
votre mois serait déjà dans une transe
douce et calme
à chaque fois que vous referai cette
plongée à chaque fois vous serez capable
d'aller encore un cran plus loin à cran
plus profondément et de dormir ensuite
plus profondément
et parce que pour bertrand piccard la
philosophie orientale a de l'importance
cela me rappelle une histoire l'histoire
de ce penseur qui s'était endormi qui
rêvaient qu'il était un papillon mais
est il vraiment un papillon qui rêvaient
qu'il avait été un homme ou un homme qui
rêvait être un papillon car le papillon
ressentait la vie le monde comme un
papillon et l'homme comme un homme et si
on est capable d'être deux choses en
même temps
y en at il une seule réelle ou bien
notre imagination at elle elle aussi
valeur de réalité et pendant que ce
penseur pensait aux papillons le
papillon aux penseurs ne sachant plus
vraiment ce qui tenait de la conscience
ou de la conscient du subconscient bien
peut-être même du rêve qui déjà dans
l'hypnose s'installe et commence à
laisser envisager le sommeil cette
capacité me disait bertrand piccard
finalement en quelque sorte à se rêver
être à la fois l'objet du rêve
le sujet vingt ans le réalisateur avoir
finalement toutes les places différentes
tous les rôles différents et savoir que
le décor la situation c'est aussi une
partie de soi
rentré en transe et découvrir son
infinie richesse sa curiosité sa
créativité et entre les mouvements
inconscient conscient en cela que
l'imaginaire tout comme une expérience
créer des apprentissages et que les
apprentis ça change les expériences en
cela que le regarde celui qui voit
de celui qui ressent aussi changent à
mesure qu'ils se changent yade mc dali
terre les mêmes choses mais autrement on
devient autres tout le temps tout en
restant semblables et on se ressent
davantage que l'on ne se connaît alors
dans cette image ou rêver d'un papillon
qui rêvent de vous dans cette
conjonction de cette réciprocité la
possibilité d'embrasser le tout est de
s'ouvrir à de nouvelles capacités de
gamme de changement d'apprentissage de
se rapproche encore davantage d'une
transe profonde et pendant que vous
pensez s'accroche se décrochent
s'accroche se décrochent pendant que vos
pensées se forment se déforme forme
d'autres forums
alors que cette jolie phrase de sartre
faire ce faisant se faire naître rien
d'autre que ce que l'on s'est fait ou
bien peut-être imaginer devient ô
combien réel au moment où la confusion
finalement permettent exprimé le
changement et de lâcher prise
alors qui n'est plus besoin de ne plus
savoir ce que l'on savait carlao le plus
grand le plus petit disparaît un des
yeux fermés vous êtes dans une transe
agréable maintenant fermez les yeux s'il
ne l'était pas déjà
prêt à vous ouvrir un voyage intérieur
un voyage de cannes de changement et
pendant que les pensées se font se
défont que l'on considère le ca le
moelleux sur moi ou toute autre instance
toute autre partie de vous même
quel qu'en soit le nom d'ailleurs que
l'on me donne cette manière de se dire
même temps être dit et de préfigurer
avant qu'ils soient exprimés le ressenti
de son savoir évidence de sa créativité
du changement permanent
cette sorte d'énergie d'eau possible qui
circulent à son rythme et se diffuse se
rencontrent s'amalgament parfois sans
kinois sans qu'il soit nécessaire de
savoir pourquoi
car déjà le centre c'est celui de vivre
le voyage et c'est finalement qui vend
que l'on se rapproche du sens car plus
on cherche le sens et puis il s'échappe
et plus envie plus on le vit lui aussi
le sens si important si proches dans
l'état de transe
cette évidence du bien-être du
changement cette capacité à entrer en
transe davantage plus calmement plus
tranquillement dans cette possibilité de
changement d'évolution dans ce
rapprochement finalement entre toutes
les choses qui pouvait sembler
divergentes
et lorsqu'ils sont intégrés hommes n'ont
pas une dialectique mais bien une
nouvelle manière de voir de comprendre
au service finalement de l'homme et non
pas au service de quelque chose
d'extérieur
dans cette combinaison qu'apporte et le
savoir et la transe et le sommeil aussi
quelque chose de plus mystérieux encore
peut-être que la trance ou le cas
parfois la transe se fait oublier
et l'on ressent tout à un niveau
inconscient et parfois c'est le
conscient qui revient et c'est très bien
comme ça
dans cette sorte eu des dalles d'envol
comme celui dit car c'est en vol vers
l'inconscient vers le changement alors
que le corps lui semble plus
profondément lui même rentré en transe
toujours davantage en transe
j'aimerais que votre esprit inconscient
vous fasse voyager dans le temps et dans
l'espace
un moment où l'humanité entière s'est
réconcilié avec la nature
certes nous sommes maintenant bien moins
nombreux mais cela permet de vivre en
équilibre avec la nature
il n'y a plus de frontières il peut
s'installer désormais où on le souhaite
et les pionniers de jadis ouvert la
possibilité à de merveilleuses
technologies respectueuses de
l'environnement l'énergie est devenue
gratuite tout ce qui est créé doit être
biodégradable il en respecte partout
l'écologie les écosystèmes
alors prenez le temps de vivre qu'en
droit dans le monde
vous aimeriez installer votre maison
désormais vous pouvez vous installer où
bon vous semble
vous pouvez vivre dans une île près de
l'océan indien
bien installé votre maison près d'un lac
au canada pour voir les couleurs de feu
les couleurs d'or de l'automne de l'été
indien bien vous pouvez vivre ce mais
d'une montagne peu importe votre
inconscient connaît ses préférences
inconscient connaît vos préférences et
cette image l'endroit où vous aimeriez
vivre
vous allez vivre vont pouvoir se
développer
parfois ce seront d'abord des sensations
des baux et et puis ensuite les images
des sons les sensations tout va pouvoir
se préciser et vous allez pouvoir
ressentir dans cet endroit où il fait
bon vivre dans cet endroit qui sera
désormais votre foyer votre lieu de
réconfort et de sécurité vous pouvez
observer la couleur du ciel
observez la végétation les bruits quel
qu'il soit venant de la nature des
animaux bedaine et puis imaginez votre
maison qui se construit qui se construit
également toute seule grâce à des
techniques d'impression en 3d la terre
sert à construire votre maison
et peu importe et peu importe la taille
qu'elle doit faire la forme bientôt
devant vos yeux les yeux de
l'inconscient vous allez pouvoir voir
votre maison construite une maison vous
vous sentirez bien qu'on sécurité et
vous serez que cette maison si un jour
vous devez partir pourra retourner
totalement la nature et c'est ce qui est
beau c'est peut-être que maintenant
cette maison est construite
je vous invite à la meubler simplement
avec les objets que vous voulez voir pas
trop d'objets ces objets ce sont des
imprimantes en 3d aussi qu'ils vont
pouvoir aller construire avec eux des
matériaux aussi dégradables
c'est pourquoi si un jour vous partez
ces objets pourront disparaître et être
créés ailleurs ton ce monde respectueux
de l'écologie c'est désormais la pensée
qui s'incarne ne crée pas des objets
pour créer des objets mais on incarne
des idées dans des objets et tous
doivent être beaux ou utiles et tous
peuvent être adaptées à votre envie à
votre créativité à votre goût et c'est
pourquoi ce refuge merveilleux pas
pouvoir ressembler à la maison de vos
rêves
sans qu'il soit besoin de croire faire
choux et vous allez vous sentir très
bien intérieurs
sécurité et paix vous pourrez ressentir
cette impression agréable de vivre au
milieu de la nature de vivre en
connexion avec la nature non pas de la
détruire de le menacer et bien de faire
partie de la nature est là où
l'intelligence de l'homme permet de
dominer construire et détruire cette
fois ci elle est utilisée pour le bien
de l'homme et de la nature
et cette sécurité de penser et ce monde
où la végétation la faune la flore tout
vient à nouveau dans une merveilleuse
diversité tout cela apporte grand
réconfort une sécurité que ceux d'avant
ne peuvent pas connaître
quel bonheur de voir la nature intacte
de voir les saisons passent et doit s'il
y en a le temps changer la couleur du
ciel la lumière changer la couleur de la
végétation de tous
il paraît qu'il n'y a pas deux brins
d'herbes identique dans une prairie et à
celui qui sait contempler la vie avec un
regard neuf et curieux chaque instant la
moindre variation de lumière le temps de
la moindre odeur fait du spectacle du
monde
le plus merveilleux plus changeants des
spectacles
ce sens bien tellement bien comment vous
cet étonnant oiseaux de fibre de carbone
bien se poser sans bruit près de votre
maison vous aviez oublié que vous
vouliez faire un voyage
c'est un ensemble maintenant de voyages
et de voyager sans bris cet avion
propulsé par la seule force ou de la
lumière qui voyagent plus doucement plus
lentement mais plus près plus près du
sol avec cette grâce merveilleuse on les
oiseaux qui peuvent planer pendant des
heures et des heures
alors oui on prend plus de temps pour se
déplacer et l'on profite du voyage alors
vous pouvez vous installer dans cet
oiseau qui souillent ory de lumière il
veut pouvoir décoller verticalement tout
d'abord dans un silence extraordinaire
comme si ne comme s'il voulait ne pas
déranger la nature
le fait est transporté dans cet oiseau
tête si bien assise ou allongée de
pouvoir tout autour en transparence et
le ciel et la terre en dessous la
sensation merveilleuse de fer avec la
nature et bientôt avec l'air avec le
monde alors tout en douceur
l'avion décolle et s'éloigne de votre
maison et vous regardez cratère cybèle
merveilleuse peut-être des rivières
peut-être des forêts des déserts des
montagnes peut-être la mer toute cette
merveilleuse tout ce merveilleux
spectacle et c'est comme si on se
retrouvait au premier jour de la
création
face à une nature intacte
qu'il est agréable de voir à nouveau les
animaux courir volet sauter un peu
partout ils sont plus nombreux ils sont
plus divers ils n'ont plus peur de
l'homme alors vous flottez vous valez
dans les airs dans cet avion merveilleux
et plus rien n'a d'importance ni le
temps ni les inquiétudes avaient déjà
disparu ces inquiétudes pour la sécurité
de cette merveilleuse maison et là c'est
l'impression d'aller encore plus loin de
vous éloigner d'elle
et comme il sera agréable bientôt
d'observer le soleil se couche et les
étoiles apparaître que le monde est beau
lorsque le soleil se retire
progressivement il y a d'abord cette
lumière c'est presque de l'or liquide
tout devient beau et puis au fur et à
mesure
parce que le soleil est presque couché
cette lumière rouge un incendie de
beauté dans le si
et quelque chose de merveilleuses m'en
irai les touchant quand avez vous vu à
coucher de soleil pour la dernière fois
la nature si belle et pris le temps le
temps de prendre son temps
alors lorsque le soleil se couche tout à
fait est que les étoiles s'allume l'une
après l'autre
d'abord l'étoile du berger puis toutes
les autres dans cette profondeur le nuit
de l'espace qu'il est drôle d'observer
l'espace et de se dire que c'est le
souvenir de milliards d'années
six toiles peut-être disparu qui
arrivent dans votre oeil à celui qui est
curieux
toute expérience magique qu'il est
agréable de voir à nouveau les étoiles
toutes les étoiles et de voir la voie
lactée
c'est vrai qu'elle semble c'est vrai
qu'elle ressemble un chemin vers le rêve
tous les rêveurs tournent leur regard
vers le ciel c'est instinctive tous les
rêveurs regarde les étoiles et tous les
rêveurs se baladant leur rêve porté par
la voie lactée avec cette curiosité de
l'inconnu et cette confiance il y a
quelque chose de merveilleux dans
l'univers et je peut le ressentir
je peux te faire mieux c'est bien plus
facile qu'on ne le croit il suffit
d'observer de se connecter de
s'émerveiller et l'on ressent soit une
impression profondément satisfaisant
plus que tu contentement plus qu une
rêverie
sans à sa place satisfaits heureux et à
ce moment là alors que vous êtes porté
toujours parce merveilleuse avions la
veille et le sommeil sans se mêler de
plus en plus et la rêverie et le rêve et
le monde de lecteurs et le monde
intérieur
à quel moment regardez-vous les étoiles
à quel moment avez vous rêvé de celle ci
à quel moment modeste la voix qui vous
accompagnait et devenait le paysage
votre avion et vos rêves et à quel
moment
étiez vous dans votre propre rêve à quel
moment vous êtes vous déjà endormi
peut-être encore plus profondément du
sommet de la trance ou peut-être du vrai
sommet de la nuit
quel plaisir que de savoir lorsque vous
dormirez bientôt vous dormirez vous
allez pouvoir être 100 personnages vivre
sans aventures de venir aux autres vivre
d'autre chose
je n'en ai jamais une prison c'est que
le rêve permet d'aller au-delà du monde
d'aller dans la multiplicité de
retrouver peut-être si l'on y croit le
temps du rêve ce cette période
et si longtemps où les hommes pouvaient
se transformer en animaux en pierre en
végétal où la magie était encore
possible nous les choses n'étaient pas
s'y fixer c'est vrai que dans le rêve
tout peut devenir tout tout est
fluctuant et c'est merveilleux de voir
de quelle manière votre inconscient peut
encore habiller votre expérience
cette expérience d'un vol silencieux et
doux vendre laisse pas planer planer au
dessus de la terre peut être observé à
la surface de quelques claques de
quelques mers ou océans des étoiles qui
se reflètent les nuages aussi la lune la
lune elle aussi une invitation à la
rêverie qu'il serait plaisant de rêver
aux sélénites ces mystérieux habitants
de la lune ou d'imaginer aller encore
plus loin un jour dans le secret de
l'espace faire quelques planètes
nouvelle habitable nous rencontrerait
d'autres vies pourquoi pas c'est le
temps du rêve de tous les possibles
jean n'a pas à juger le rêve juste à le
vivre à s'en nourrir mais pendant clip
ans et sa crosse décroche pendant que
l'on continue ce va merveilleux qui va
pouvoir durer aussi longtemps que vous
le souhaitez peut-être un mort et vous
envie de vous poser quelque part pour
retrouver le contact du sein et vous
nourrir vous rechargez presque de la
beauté du monde
[Musique]
tous vous appartient vous pouvez aller
où bon vous semble
c'est cela cette merveilleuse sensation
de liberté vient de là se sentir
connectés se sentir libre ils en sont
dormir et on s'endormant conscient se
réveiller à l'inconscient et aux rêves
et alors que ce voyage va pouvoir non se
poursuivre
que vous décidiez de continuer à voler
ou à vous poser quelque part ma voix
elle va se transformer une sorte de
murmures avoir deux mois sont moins
d'importance
alors que le sommet lui s'installera de
plus en plus car dans l'observation de
soi du monde alors qu'une partie déjà
puis le sommeil alors qu'une partie déjà
vie le sommeil tout une autre partie
cela se border tranquillement la
respiration toujours régulière la
respiration du dorment la respiration de
celui qui rêve
les très détendue car serein tranquille
dans cette manière de lâcher prise
finalement de laisser aux mots
simplement la possibilité d'être audi
sont peut-être parfois une évocation et
de les laisser partir pour soi-même
approfondir la transe tout temps tout ce
changement permanent du mois dans cet
aller-retour voire davantage entre
conscience a conscience peu importe le
terme que non emploi car tout est vrai
dans le rêve tout est second et vous
pouvez continuer à dormir dormir
complètement sereinement
porté par mes mots comme cet avion est
porté par l'air et propulsé par ce
premier moteur menu celui de
l'imagination de ma conscient continuer
cette rêverie jusqu'au territoire
durèrent tranquillement sereinement
comme cela
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec le fit aux
nuits fit aux nuits en sachet à infuser
un mélange innovant de mélatonine
l'hormone naturelle du sommeil et de
cinq plants pour s'endormir et bien
dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire fit aux nuits